no no doggone it no yeah I can't
remember the [ __ ] lines oh yes what's
wrong with you people this is the same
debate when people tell me that ghost
bus the original Ghostbusters wasn't the
comedy it's a comedy [ __ ] you it takes
place at Christmas time it's got
Christmas trees in it it takes place in
a Christmas party it's about him going
home for Christmas to see his family and
then mayhem happens and he's having
mayhem and shooting up a thing around
Christmas decorations and then it ends
with let it snow let it snow let it snow
I'm this debate I'm sorry I'm shutting
it down
it's a Christmas movie don't ever
challenge me on this again where do you
come from heaven no no you sit there and
you you spin your little web and you no
no I tell you no I'm not gonna do it
it's not the greatest Christmas movie of
all time is the greatest movie of all
time
it's my favorite movie I think it is the
greatest Christmas movie of all time
because it just it does everything a
Christmas movie in a movie in general
was supposed to do which is got such
great characters the story is so
compelling you just get drawn into this
guy's life you care about him and the
structure of it is so amazing because
you kind of spend so much time learning
about this guy you've kind of figured
that's the movie and then when he
crashes and burns then you get the whole
Christmas Carol version of like here's
what the light your life would have been
like if you weren't around I mean Sagada
guy wanted to kill himself you know
that's pretty heavy-duty especially for
when it came out in the 1930s the most
important thing is when it ends you're
so happy it's Christmastime if you're
watching Christmas cuz you go oh I'm
glad it's Christmas and I want to have
all the settings that they have in the
movie have trees and beautiful things
and fun and love and family
Zuzu's petals Zuzu's petals Harry what
how'd you take your shoes off why the
hell are you dressed like a chicken home
alone the first one I'm sorry its home
alone - no personally I find the home
alone - rather disturbing he's watching
that old movie and it's it's the most
misogynist movie I've ever seen in my
life with this guy you filthy animal and
he like machine guns a woman it's like
is this supposed to be entertaining I'm
so upset oh but the home alone number
one is hilarious
you know mom he he knocks out a bunch of
intruders in his house and he got
Katherine yeah it's good Christmas movie
in the same way that die hard is a
Christmas movie actually even more so
because it's got the most insane speech
ever in the world which we were watching
in the theater in opening weekend and
our jaws hit the ground when Phoebe
Cates is telling the story of dad
disappears and suddenly they smell they
smelled the smell and he died as Santa
Claus in the chimney that's that's got
to get a special award for being one of
the most bananas things I've ever seen
in my life
I say the Griswolds I think there's just
something so much more fun about them
well first of all McAllister's left
their kid so you know that right there
is not good but secondly I don't know
Randy Quaid is so funny in that movie
that movie has one of my favorite shots
of all time comedy shots and it's just
when when Chevy Chase is going down the
hill on that disk that they just made
the decision that in one shot he was
gonna spin all the way around on that
disc is when I was a kid I used to have
a disc and it all I would do is spin
backwards and end up slamming into a
tree so I don't know I I'm a sucker for
that one and just that sequence of him
on that disc is hilarious come on with
the the sparks coming out from under it
and all done in camera priests priests
egi I'm all furred comedy in camera oh
[Music]
that's a tough I mean I am a Krampus fan
but I gotta go with the Grinch I think
the Grinch is a little more wily I think
he well let's say after his experience
when his heart grew I think he still
retains his evil but he's a little
smarter and a little more savvy around
the human condition and so I think he
could he could figure out a way to
outsmart Krampus but Krampus comes in a
close second I would say there I would
say there wouldn't be many people
standing I think maybe the Grinch might
be up on his knees and Krampus might be
lounging on his elbow Oh
[Music]
this has been Paul Feig for a movie
debates the Christmas edition
[Music]